- [Both] Bacon is good for me.
- Bacon is the best.
- I was born for bacon.
- I don't actually like bacon.
(screech)
- Who the (bleep) doesn't like bacon?
- I'm so so on sushi.
- I don't think sushi
can be improved by bacon.
- I actually expect this to be bad.
- What?
- Just grab it, you don't have the skills.
- OK, and this looks
like a McDonalds' bacon.
- It's so good.
- I'm not into it.
- I'm happy.
- Might have ruined bacon
for me a little bit.
- It's like a breakfast sushi roll.
It's pretty good.
- The sushi overpowers the bacon.
- It certainly doesn't need it.
- (bleep)
- I'm into that.
- This might be very weird.
- Ooh, that smells really good.
- It does look like maple syrup.
- Oh man, this is scary.
- Eweew.
- Smoother, but it's not,
like, the flavor of bacon.
- The fat really dulls
the flavor of everything.
- Little trendy for me.
- Oh, I only eat bananas
to be a good person.
- I love bananas.
- Umm, that kinda smells
like, like breakfast.
Kinda smells like pancakes.
- I figure this is gonna
taste like (bleep).
- [Guy] Yeah.
- [Gal] Umm hmm.
- [Guy] Yep.
- Oh, this is so good.
- This is genius.
- It's getting the whole tongue.
- It's sweet and salty.
- Yeah.
- It has that umami thing going on.
- There isn't enough of this in the world.
- I'd do that.
- Like at the end of most drunk nights,
I just wanna make bacon anyway.
- Cheers.
- Ooh, that is good.
- You taste it when you breathe out?
- It's like, makes it
just easier to drink.
- It's putting hair on my chest.
- It makes it more
special than the average
Friday night whiskey.
- This is making me question everything.
- Life's got you down, just take a swig
from that big whiskey.
- If you're willin' to get drunk,
why not get drunk off bacon?
- I'm drunk already.
- [Both] I like it, I love
it, I'll eat some more of it.
- [Guy in blue] Bacon.
I just want you to know
this is a very special
time in my life, and I'm
just so glad I can be
sharing it with you.
- [Girl in black] Are you falling in love?
- [Guy in blue] Yeah, I am in love.
With bacon.
I'm in love with bacon.
- Bacon love.